welcome to this video playing Yemm from
Spain let's see I'm Sicilian and open
salient let's play the con variation
pretty flexible flexible set up okay so
he's going for a very classical
development yeah I don't think b5 as a
good move here Bishop f3f fingers the
problem hmm this is possible to play
move like that I don't know
so it's some pretty unconventional way
of playing here with with them the
bishop on c5 key lets in its castle
first the pawn on d6 of course is
potentially week but I hope do you wanna
maybe maybe I should put it here to
allow for a night move to increase the
coverage of the porn hmm yeah he's
simply doubling
yeah this is not not too great I guess
this Bishop c5 idea was yeah maybe
creative boots not not successful this
looks so nice for white but it's not so
clear how exactly who is here how
exactly he is going to make something um
concrete out of that
try night see form right back to f3
yeah I want to go here for them to take
known queen before as a possible idea
maybe rookie for smooth yeah this night
only ate it looks very passive but the
thing is it's passive but it has got a
very important function and how to slide
exactly threaten d6 with a minor piece
to to win the pawn I don't see how and
now I'm intending before try to get to
the sea to porn finally
yeah maybe it isn't so bad for work
I'm not sure what is some supposed to do
now
because let's say rook t2 and look 42
our go before and take you for
yeah this looks rather passive but hmm
maybe maybe it was was necessary okay if
I go here PM nighty for my queen bee
five and then e 5 i'm winning you
forward
yeah no way to prepare to UM to protect
you for just going to take it next move
I just got the offside night yeah summer
whites I got outplayed out of out of
nothing almost and now I even have the
smoothest even stronger Knight takes e4
is a very big fork and this activates my
ugly night only eight sort of getting
resurrected till night f64 and here's no
way to predict the bond wait resonate
yeah what a strange game it looked right
here I thought oh wow I'm really passive
here and then somehow this kind of this
kind of position got to dynamic yeah
okay it looks passer but the house white
going to make any progress against this
it's a typical Hedgehog phenomenon
sometimes you you look pensive but
that's very hardly any way to progress
and your black is probably all right now
probably this this this is some yeah
okay h3 is certainly certainly very lame
move after b5 it's it gets tricky yeah
here black already has got some edge and
this goes down here really quickly
yeah and this is really winning Knight
takes e4 is coming no way to prevent it
can you can save the exchange something
like that but look at this look at this
this is a potential idea yeah terrible
yes what a strange position I mean
somehow we got to a point where
whiteheads has problems too to make any
progress quite often the problem of this
Hedgehog structures is that the only
progress for white there was a side
against the Hedgehog is to to do any
pawn pushes you need to advance like f4
f5 f45 or another kind of positions with
G for you need to move your your your
pieces you pawns sorry and it's hard to
make any progress with pieces on Lydia
it's not yeah like I've got the Hedgehog
but the pawn is 1 C 2 is also a
different thing here this be five before
really attacks the sea to point at the
end yeah it really seems that black
black is ok here because why doesn't
really have any great act of plants
connected with the with pawns yeah I'm
still amazing that black hair got the
upper hand so quickly I was surprised
myself yeah it's already yet already bad
for white all right interesting typical
Sicilian game thanks for watching